In education accountability era things
that don't boost math and reading scores
have fallen out of favor that includes
field trips but is this really much of a
loss after all most of us can recall a
field trip that seemed more like a lark
than a learning experience that's what
makes the pioneering research by my
friend University of Arkansas professor
Jay Greene so compelling using a gold
standard random assignment methodology
Greene has studied the impact of museum
visits and trips to the theater to see a
Shakespearean play he found that these
field trips had a significant impact on
knowledge retention remarkably he also
found that such trips
similarly boosted students tolerance and
empathy why green suggests that these
experiences help students register
things in ways that they don't in a
classroom setting Greene's work is a
valuable argument that experiences which
have been pushed aside in our test
obsessed era may deserve a second look
what do you think about field trips let
us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI